federal government is cracking down on
what it describes as unscrupulous stem
cell clinics selling unapproved
treatments for eye problems scientists
say the stem cells are capable of
generating different types of cells and
tissues they offer the possibility of
treating conditions like heart disease
diabetes and Stroke the Justice
Department filed for injunctions this
month against two companies that have
used stem cells on people's eyes seeking
to prevent them from experimenting on
patients Manuel Bojorquez spoke with a
woman who claims she was blinded as a
result of this procedure he joins us at
the table good to see you man good to
see you too and good morning many people
with fading vision have turned to stem
cell therapy believing it's their only
shot of reversing their conditions but
the federal government hasn't approved
the treatment so they're being performed
as clinical research while some patients
have reported improvements others have
fared much worse it just sounded this is
stupid to say but too good to be true
and it it was too good to be true it was
the promise of hope against the
incurable disease blurring doris Tyler's
vision she says workers at a clinic in
Georgia repeated a claim on their
website that stem cells may be effective
in the treatment of macular degeneration
I'm sure you both talked it over pretty
extensively what was the consensus you
reached with the information that you
had Doris and her husband Donald paid
eighty nine hundred dollars for an
experimental procedure in which the
clinic removed fat from her belly
harvested stem cells from it and
injected them into her eyes within three
months
she says both her retinas had detached
leaving her blind the birds out on the
bird feeder and the beautiful flowers
that dogs planted in the yard the
Tyler's have filed a lawsuit against the
clinic and the cell surgical Network
with which its affiliated they claimed
the risk of danger from the procedure
outweighs the non-existent benefits of a
therapy with no evidence of therapeutic
value I often refer to these cells as
you know
magical cells despite sales pitches by
the founders of cell surgical network
they are capable of fixing anything the
FDA has not approved the treatments in
fact the agency has warned about
unscrupulous providers who offer
stem-cell products that are both
unapproved and unproven the Justice
Department has filed civil cases against
cell Surgical Network and another
provider accusing them of a persistent
refusal to comply with the law honestly
my impression is that there is minimal
of any regulation dr. Thomas Albini
teaches at the Bascom Palmer Eye
Institute he examined Doris Tyler and
others who've reported vision loss after
stem cell injections he warns patients
should be aware of any treatment that
isn't fda-approved and any providers who
charge for participation in research
when they go to these clinics they're
stepping outside of mainstream American
medicine yet there have been some
apparent success stories we have to do
something we can't just sit back and
wait for mother nature Beth course power
owns a machine shop in Elkhart Indiana
she reports macular degeneration robbed
her of the ability to read and see faces
she estimates spending about $60,000 for
three procedures using stem cells from
her bone marrow I knew I didn't have
much choice it was either that I'd go
completely blind and that was
unacceptable she says she can now see
the people she's talking to and read
with the help of a magnifier I would do
it all over again the cell surgical
network wasn't involved in Gerst hours
treatment but in an email to CBS News
one of its founders says this is a new
way of helping patients heal insisting
it is safe and clean in a statement the
organization said it shares the concern
for patient safety yet strongly rejects
the idea that a person's own cells
should be regulated by the FDA as a drug
Donald and Dora's Tyler say they want
others to hear their story before
considering these treatments God knows I
don't want anybody else to go through
what I'm going through right now the
Georgia clinic the treated doors Tyler
declined to comment emeral regulators
advisors considering stem-cell
treatments to ask if the FDA has
reviewed the treatment and to make sure
they understand all of the known risks
before signing the consent form to
participate in any clinical trial
I'm glad Doris Tyler's sharing her story
it's a cautionary tale to be sure when
you're desperate you'll try anything
absolute she started the piece if it
sounds too good to be true then on the
other lady it worked that's right and
that's what is needs to be out there
right that's still experimental that
even if a doctor is trying to convince
you is the right thing to do ask all the
questions you need to feel comfortable
yeah we're going forward with Iron Man
well thanks